is this what I really want to do because
there were other times in my life when I
thought about this I thought about it
when I did legislation and actually it
was in the state Senate and I don't know
if this is gonna be relatable or not but
I want to say it anyhow because I've
always wanted to just mention this
because I think it's important away this
is not was not a complex bill it was not
something that was you know very
difficult to understand it isn't
intellectually stimulating to some
people I understand but I did two bills
and one of them it's unusual for New
Jersey would allow in any public or
private building to have In God We Trust
on the wall and the second one was that
you could fly the American flag wherever
you wanted to however you wanted to as
long as it was respectful and I thought
these were wonderful bills I mean I
thought everybody was going to be this
is just a great thing and I had some
very progressive and not all Democrats
but these were really progressive
Democrats that came to me and said we're
really discussed it with you I said why
making such a big deal about the flag
the flag is just not that big a deal
and god we trust' this without that big
deal and you shouldn't even mention his
name and I was shocked I was shocked we
put him up anyhow and we did what we
wanted to do but it really is a very
Republican thing but I know I'm gonna
find any one of us that I can tell you
Kevin Mike I think you're ok with it and
I think most folks should be ok with
them the whole country should be ok with
it you're right I talked about American
exceptionalism this is the greatest
country on the face of the earth I
started out as not a wealthy kid had the
opportunity to work hard got into dental
school graduated oh my god I'm sitting
here next to the President of the United
States
that's unbelievable that's America so I
don't want anybody to ever tell me that
there isn't American exceptionalism I
don't want anybody to ever say that this
is the same as every other country in
the world because it is not it is not
and you know that and
know that and hopefully everybody in
this room knows that and again from
certain groups of people that represent
in certain parts of the party I was
criticized and they said this country is
the same as every other country and
there is no such thing as American
exceptionalism I'm a capitalist
socialism in my opinion has no place in
the United States of America and I think
everyone should know that I believe that
this country can afford people
opportunity and give them that
opportunity so that they can succeed and
when you all should know that as well
I love bipartisanship do you know that I
even had times quite frankly being a
Democrat again not from all folks
there's some middle-of-the-road folks
but from some of these extreme folks
that they said bipartisanship is a bad
thing yeah it's a bad thing because it's
gonna make you more like a Republican
again I don't believe that I don't think
you do I believe in what you're doing
with the economy it's a better stronger
economy a new records it is better it's
up 125 points today so your 401ks are
way up but a new record today Jeff so
that's great and and thank you for that
I believe in the new Green Deal is
something that we should never ever even
think about doing I don't even know how
anybody could bring that up we can't
have a strong and good environment and
we can't have a good economy at the same
time and that's something that I think
republicanism represents lower taxes
balancing the budget
honoring or police or fire or rescue our
veterans our soldiers these men and
women I want to tell you one quick story
Chris will have a picture of it he's
like I said he's a Marine an older
gentleman and is he a marine too that
stood out there he's a marine right an
older gentleman when he heard I
announced in the cold came in front of
my office and stood out there holding
the American flag friend it was amazing
thing and not quite the people didn't
length of time people wait for you okay
they won't do that of you're a Democrat
I can tell you right now so when you go
well I guess what I say is I believe
that this is just a better fit for me
this is Who I am the two I always was
but there was more tolerance of moderate
Democrats of Blue Dog Democrats of
conservative Democrats and I think
that's going away two more things I want
to say one you have my undying support
thank you thank you always and by the
way the same way
thank you I'm endorsing him okay we're
endorsing him I can't speak for these
two gentlemen but I can say I'm
endorsing him thank you how do you feel
about that Mike and the last thing I
will say one of my heroes and he's
always hung in my office I have a
bipartisan wall that has a lot of
different people on there Ronald Reagan
and when he said I didn't leave my party
my party left me that's true that's what
he said and I'm saying the same thing he
was a Democrat and he he he moved over
and he said exactly those words it's
fantastic thank you Thank You
congressman it's an honor to share this
moment with you with President of the
United States and with the Republican
leader with your team and their family
as well as I know another public
official from New Jersey that'll be
following your lead and right but as I
told you before I also I just want to
tell you how grateful we are for your
voice of reason and common sense in the
days leading up to your decision you
showed personal and political courage
and I know the people of your district
will be as grateful as we are today for
your leadership and for the decision
you've made and we look forward we look
forward to serving with you together and
working with you on behalf of New Jersey
in America for many years to come
Thank You mr. vice president thank you
Kevin
we just want to welcome you to the party
but more importantly if there's anybody
else that feels like you there are other
people out there that feel the this new
socialist Democrat wing of the party has
left them behind join with us
because everything you talked about is
an American issue they shouldn't
shouldn't have to be debated whether
there's a flag or God or others and so
we've worked together even when you were
on the other side of the aisle it's nice
to have you on this side now - thank you
and you you just changed our number to
18 we only need 18 more to be the
majority and I think we'll do that so
we're gonna do very well we're way up in
the polls and we've done up more I think
proportionately than we have ever gone
up in the last two weeks and we're
honored now I understand they're playing
games they don't want to put in their
articles they're ridiculous phony
fraudulent articles and I think they're
not allowed to do that
here it's unconstitutional and a lot of
other things but they don't want to put
them in because they're ashamed of them
because it's what they've done is wrong
and it's bad for the country very very
bad for the country trying to get us mca
done we're gonna get that done i think
pretty quickly we have our great deal
with china china has already started to
buy with the farmers and with the
manufacturers tremendous amounts of
money are being spent back in the united
states and the farmers are happy they
had to put up with a lot but we took
care of them out of the subsidies that
we were getting out of the out of the
tariffs that we were getting but china
is now buying very big in the farm bill
and in the manufacturing belt also
they're spending a lot of money and i
said it was going to happen and it
happened and we're gonna get a lot more
they want to make they want to keep
going they're still paying tremendous
amounts of tariffs and they'd like to
have the tariffs reduced and we'll see
if we can get a second part of the deal
but the u.s. MCA the combination of
those two deals will be the two greatest
trade deals you'll never see anything
like it so we've done very much what we
said you know Jeff we rebuilt our
military we spent almost two and a half
trillion dollars on the military when we
came in the military was totally
depleted I will say the Democrats did
not help they're not into the military
at all and we spent two and a half
trillion we have new planes we have new
everything right now much of its coming
over the next year but within a year
we'll be in a position that we've never
been in in terms of equipment and
the military will be as strong as it
ever was proportionately maybe stronger
so it's been an amazing period of time
and to have you as a tremendous asset
for the party and again thank you very
much thank you you over thank you thank
you with you tremendous honor thank you
just tell us what does it feel like to
be the third president in US history to
be impeached well I don't feel like I'm
being impeached because it's a hoax it's
a setup it's a horrible thing they did
they happen to have a small majority and
they took that small majority and they
forced people and you know they said oh
I watched Pelosi out there saying oh no
we don't want to talk to anybody they
put the arm on everybody they tried to
get them to do what they had to do many
of those people were like Jeff where
they didn't want to vote that way but it
doesn't feel to me it doesn't feel like
impeachment last night I said it I we
had a great time last night the room was
packed
thousands of people couldn't get in a
section that really is a pretty much
50/50 section in terms of Democrat
Republican we had every one of those
people is voting for Trump Pence every
one of them and it's Michigan an
important state we brought back
tremendous amounts of business
tremendous car companies coming and
everything else and I'll tell you I was
up there and I was thinking about I
actually said it it doesn't feel like
impeachment and you know what it's a
phony deal and they cheapen the word
impeached it's an ugly word but they
cheapen the word impeachment that should
never again happen to another president
and I think you'll see some very
interesting things happen over the
coming few days and weeks but to me all
I look at we have the greatest economy
in the history of our country we've
never done so well our military being
rebuilt you take a look at the tax cuts
you take a look at the regulation cuts
at levels that nobody has ever seen
we're protecting our Second Amendment
which other people won't do now we're
doing things that nobody's ever done
before nobody's ever seen we have the
strongest economy in the history of our
country and our countries doing well and
you know the other thing that I really
saw from yes
that I think you people have been
covering politics for a long time you've
never seen a Republican Party zero
negative votes zero that hasn't happened
almost ever because the Republicans are
not necessarily known for that we have
better policy they want open borders the
Democrats they want sanctuary cities a
lot of bad things happen a lot of other
things they have we're doing
tremendously on health care the
individual mandate you know we won
yesterday in Supreme Court you saw that
in the Appellate Division we won
yesterday individual mandate is now gone
that's tremendous savings that was the
worst part of Obamacare we take care of
pre-existing conditions they're not
going to be able to do that we're doing
things that nobody's ever done before
and our country has never done better so
we're really happy about it and we're
really happy to have Jeff on board and
we think in 2020 based on the polls I
just saw a poll came out in USA Today
yesterday where I'm beating every
candidate by a lot I guess most of you
said not that USA Today is a friend of
mine because they're not but they had a
poll and it was me against their top
candidates on the other side and I'm
beating everybody by a lot and I think
that's where we're going I mean we have
the best economy in history and if you
remember the famous quote it's all about
the economy stupid well I never believed
it was all about the economy but the
economy is a big thing when you have
401ks where people are up 70 80 90 and
even more than that percent they like
Trump and they like Mike and we're gonna
have a good time thank you all very much
thank you thank you
[Music]
you tell us a little bit about your
strategy for the Senate trial we think
that what they did is wrong we think
that what they did is unconstitutional
and the Senate is very very capable
we have great senators Republican
senators we cut your taxes we cut your
regulations we did things that nobody
else would even think about being able
to do and I think you know one of the
things Jeff that we've done that nobody
wants to talk about this week I will
have signed the 170 second federal judge
including appellate judges will have a
hundred and eighty two by the end of the
one hundred and eighty two it's unheard
of now President Obama was very nice to
us he gave us a hundred and forty two
empty positions that's never happened
before but as you know that's said to be
the most important thing that a
president has I happen to think military
and defense and all of is the most
important thing but this is right up
there we'll have a hundred and seventy
two judges we're gonna have a hundred
eighty two by the end of the year or
shortly thereafter and it's the most
incredible thing and two Supreme Court
justices two great ones so with all of
the things we've done and we've done
that with the Senate because what's
never said is that in the last election
we picked up two Senate seats nobody
talks about that and we couldn't focus
on the house I couldn't focus on the
house will be very focused on the house
this time but I couldn't other than Andy
Barr who won against the same candidate
that's now going against Mitch and she
wasn't very good against Andy Barr and
she won't be very good against Mitch
McConnell but we've had tremendous
success so I'm gonna let them decide
what to do that's going to be up to them
thank you all very much
yeah I ain't gonna be your maid lawyer
in the Senate it looks like that yeah
batshit Polonia we have a couple of
others that we're gonna put in but
that's been fantastic as White House
Counsel thank you
[Music]
[Music]
but harmfulness you've just a seminar at
the war you admire or somebody who has
it better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]